i'm eric dodds I'm the game director for
hearthstone and I'm excited because we
just announced our second adventure for
hearthstone it's called Blackrock
Mountain and so what it's going to do is
add a bunch of different single-player
missions that the player is going to be
able to play through and so defeat
various bosses of Blackrock Mountain
single player and as they defeat those
bosses they earn cards that they get to
add to their deck so they get to change
the deck that they're playing in
multiplayer with those brand new cards
are getting so this is the very first
mission of Blackrock Mountain this is
the battle against corn dire brew in the
grim guzzler so each of these missions
the enemy that you're fighting against
has a very different power and makes you
think very differently how you normally
would play a game of hearthstone so for
instance you see his hero power there
you when he uses his hero power each
player puts a minion from their deck
into the battlefield so it could be a
very expensive minion and they don't
have to pay for it so it makes you think
maybe I don't want to just use my normal
man occur when I'm when I'm building a
deck for this maybe I want to play very
very differently so you know as he's
playing he's thinking about these these
changes that we have to make to play the
game and all of our missions throughout
Blackrock Mountain all 17 missions we
have in all five wings operate in a very
different way but they still make you
think very differently about how you
play hearthstone which is pretty awesome
and then again you get to get some of
these cards for instance he has the
black wing technician right there you
can see the the power it has it's one of
the new cards that you can get from
blackrock mountain and it allows you to
build a deck that's all about dragons
and that's one of the things Blackrock
Mountain is about it's about building a
deck with tons of awesome dragons in it
whereas before you could build a deck
that you know had a couple of dragons in
it but it really had another theme now
you could build a deck that's really
focused on that and that's pretty
awesome but again what really Blackrock
Mountain is is facing a bunch of
different really interesting bosses
changing the way you think about horse
stone and then getting awesome cards
that sort of affect the way you play the
game forever after once you've earned
those cards and that's what Blackrock
Mountain is a our amazing second
adventure
you